so a little while ago I asked people to
submit applications to something called
the Ox log project this was a project
which essentially continued my ox log
project from last year every week I made
a video blog about my life in Oxford
trying to dispel with people's
misconceptions and stereotypes they
might believe about these students at
the University and the application
process soon as the project was
successful and I was leaving Oxford I
went at other people to take it over and
I thought it could be improved by having
multiple people taking part on the
project in particular five people and
after some utterly fantastic entries to
the ox log project those five people
have not been chosen I'd like to say to
everybody who submitted a video thank
you so much the quality of entries to
the project was phenomenal frankly I
would have happily watched an entire
year's worth of video blogs from every
single one of you and I am utterly
gutter that I can only pick five people
say thank you so much however I could
only choose five people and I'm gonna
let them introduce themselves and talk a
little bit more about the project in
their own words hi I'm Danny and I'm a
lawyer
back to college my name is Daniel and
I'm in my first year studying human
sciences of new college my name is Annie
and I am a third year student studying
English I'm done I'm in my second year
at Humber College
I study physics my name is Rachel I'm a
penny more I said biomedical sciences
each of us on a specific day of the week
is going to upload a video of what
they've been up to over the last week
I'll be living on my thing Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday and Friday each
octave log has to obey a set of rules no
more than five minutes long includes
both their work life and social life you
cannot miss the video if any of these
rules are broken then the other vloggers
have to enforce punishment on them use
the comments as an ask us anything space
and we mean it ask us anything or we're
not going to do this give your roast
interview of what life is like here here
you can do to yourself of something
you've heard about the university is to
show you the ground from a perspective
make sure you subscribe to the channel
that way you'll see with videos as there
if you're applying to a university or if
you're just interested in the life or
not to you join us on this project
thanks for watching guys
so if you want an honest student's
perspective on life at Oxford then
please do subscribe to the channel
there's a link up on screen right now
there's also a link in the description
if you watching this on mobile and
please do subscribe there are going to
be some fantastic videos I can tell you
now they're a really interesting bunch
of people they cover the entire Brett
the University and I'm really excited to
see what this project goes
sorry about the background by the way
I've only just moved into Exeter
so I'm kind of finding camera angles
I'll be doing an update video quite seen